hello everyone welcome back and now it's
our last talk um it's
let's welcome
dr hansen kang from university wisconsin
madison
[Applause]
also thank you again for the organizer
caroline and bin and our people at the
staff as well for actually organizing
this and making sure this runs on uh
thank you again also for staying till
stick to the end so this this talk will
be on something that my student uh now
actually now dr conchala uh worked on uh
for about two years on how to do
randomized experiments under privacy
constraints so this is something that
actually i just goes to the overview of
this talk so
the idea came actually and some um this
part actually the talk is organized this
way but the problem the way we got the
problem was actually in the bottom up
where
i was kind of frustrated that we weren't
able to get individual level clinical
trials data and it actually takes
forever to get these things and even if
you get them you're going to get summary
statistics of them and in fact for
better transparent scientific
replication it's important that we
actually have these individual level
data so that not only can you build
different models different machine
learning models at the top of it but
also to combine
experimental data so you get more power
out of it so then also constantly our
staff department wanted to have a
different way of evaluating online
courses at the same time
and tasked us to actually come up with a
way to evaluate courses but there still
protects uh student privacy specific
student educational records those are
protected under ferpa and so given those
we
thought about this rivet then we came up
with a design that actually estimates
causal effects under the constraints of
privacy specifically differential
privacy a lot of you might be familiar
with this berkeley kind of stat
department berkeley has kind of really
took this off to a different level
and so that's the idea how do you
construct a randomized experiments under
constraints of privacy so the uh we're
going to review a couple concepts that
might be familiar to some of you not but
all not all of you so one of them is
local differential privacy that's common
in cs and stats
the other one is something
uh called non-adherence and cheating
that actually borrow ideas from
experimental psychology but these
psychologists actually have a very
clever way of testing whether you're a
cheater or non-shooter so we kind of
take this and take it to modern levels
and then we combine these very two
simple ideas with sample splitting to
come up with uh rct that's also
differentially private and can
consistently estimate the ate and do
inference as well uh
there's a nice theory here but i mean i
think theory can be nicer than i said
and one of the things that we are kind
of wanting to explore in the future is
the trade-off between efficiency
relative efficiency and how much privacy
we're losing by doing these kind of
experiments okay
so just to review the gold standard
to unbiased estimate the ate is usually
the rct where you randomly assign a
treatment a to individuals and they
observe the outcome typically the best
way you send some people to treatment
some people to control this is the ideal
case and if you take the difference in
means of these things these are unbiased
estimates of the ate
now um these are used a lot in education
health tech a b testing social sciences
you name it this is how it's done and if
you have resources to do so
but one of the implicit assumptions
that's in an rct that's not even covered
in the uh the sudvas or the positivities
or the condition of normal abilities is
that the participant that's protesting
in child is actually going to be willing
to participate in the trial and also
give true responses to their uh true
responses to their treatment so
what but what if that response is very
sensitive in nature so the other one
would be what if the pis myself included
or maybe the clinical trials folks
wanted to actually share their data
about some cholesterol drug or something
to that to the public and so that they
can actually not replicate but also
combine these data to even consult more
powerful tests
and
and some of these responses are actually
protected by law and some of these
things are at ferpa which is the one
we're more interested in when you did
online education on when they ran our
trial
but hipaa is the reason for health data
and gdpr all the cookie except the
cookie don't accept the cookies that you
see in your chrome browser that's a
that's for and it depends on which
country you're into actually and then
california has his own version so if you
actually notice a california view
there's its own jeep version of gdpr
and some examples of the sensitive
responses include the more famous
example about voting that facebook
facebook done where actually they merged
uh voting people's voting records with
these voting buttons to see how these
the the impact of having these friends
on whether you actually participate in
voting but the one to your left is that
what we actually did which is what is
the effect of actually having an
instructor present in a zoom session
while they're lecturing on the
participation rate test scores and all
these other things that's one of the
things that the department was
interested in learning and in both of
these cases the response here could be
uh here was educational outcomes and
here's quoting records should ideally
private okay that you don't you don't
want to share this data that people
don't want to share their gpas or test
score results and so how do we do
science transparent science
while guaranteeing privacy
that's the question that we're trying to
tackle today now we're not the only ones
kind of weak
we looked at this there are many ways
you can kind of tackle this question and
so we draw out this very diagrammatic
way on the y-axis is maximizing data
privacy on the x-axis is essentially
maximizing scientific value replication
you can see the individual data you can
toy around of all the data collection
you wanted and so on the top right axis
here if you don't want to if you don't
ever run around ict to get science you
get you maximize privacy you never even
have to collect data in the first place
that's not all that's not in the case so
oftentimes most of the most of the
spectra in practice that lives here
where people measure the summary stats
or people actually only do
give you aggregate responses so this is
summary level responses and there's also
some literature in the database world on
how to aggregate them properly
and then on the other end of the spectra
is maximizing scientific value where you
run the rcts don't care about the laws
share everything and then hopefully you
have honest science but then you know
people don't want their clinical trials
to be out in the world
so the problem is that most of the
current world lives here around this
middle area where you share the
aggregate information or share dna
identified information but the problem
is probably the people in differential
privacy know this it's actually fairly
easy to uh well reasonably easy to on on
identity identify the identified data
set so they actually i then re-identify
the de-identified data set but actually
through data merging and there's a
famous uh example by sweeney i think in
about 2000 where they were able to
identify the people from netflix
anonymized from netflix but just by
merging a couple things together
and so that's one thing the other thing
from a statistical angle is that the
trade-off between how to do inference
while guaranteeing privacy is not
actually clear so this is just a diagram
we're not explicitly on how to
quantifying how this trade-off appears
so what our approach or this design is
an rprct robust differentially private
rct that actually not only is that rough
we think that would work at this angle
but also quantify this trade-off in a
relative sense okay
so let me just review two concepts to
explain what our prc is the first one is
differential privacy so this one some of
you may be familiar with
we take the easiest example this is not
the first reference by the way of
differential privacy so the idea of
differential privacy is take summer's
true response you put it into some
algorithm and it spits out a privatized
response okay so for example if your
true response is something uh if you're
if you're always if your algorithm is
always spitting out one that's perfectly
differentiated private that means
regardless of what your true response is
if the algorithm always produces one you
can never recover back what the
individual original outcome was and
that's called zero privacy or really
perfect privacy
yeah the other end of the spectra is
where the algorithm spits out the
original true sensitive response all the
time and that's infinite sentence that's
infinitely a differentially private or
there's infinite privacy loss
and what differential privacy does
essentially it quantifies this middle
ground here at the two extremes and
this epsilon differential privacy is uh
it's now actually adopted by certain
tech companies apple adopts this or
apple health data if you if we ever use
safari
it also uses a certain type of episode
of differential privacy to send this
data back to the servers to actually do
some studies or quick type the one that
does your uh
auto completes as well and then you
google google and uber i think also uses
this system to actually do science to do
a b testing while simultaneously
guaranteeing privacy okay so this is the
formal definition uh some of you who are
actually seeing this literature probably
are familiar with this but the
punch line is essentially
some very very very very smart people
we've quantified uh privacy by
essentially saying if i have two true
responses there's this algorithm such
that this algorithm if you the outputs
of this algorithm are very very similar
even though that the true response is
very very different from one another so
that's roughly what this says and the
epsilon essentially uh it's a
quantification of how different between
those outputs are
okay so let me just give you an
illustrative example just from uh
actually this is what we use uh from
when we actually render a dice version
of this so suppose the
the question that we were interested in
the population quantitative interest is
whether somebody paid attention to
lecture so if let's say lecturer wants
to ask
an online zoom call online lecture
whether you want to paid a less
intention so bob's true response is that
he never did he was just sleeping he
didn't he turned off his video camera
and he never actually played a single
single thing about the regression okay
now what the fr algorithms the
differential private algorithm does is
it lets bob spin one of this thing and
then if the spinner lands in red bob is
asked to say no with the spinner lens in
green the bob is asked to say yes and if
the spinner lands in blue it does bob is
actually going to respond honestly okay
and so in this case the spinner lands in
red and bob's privatize response that he
reports to us will be no and if the
spinner lands in green the bob will
always say yes even though his true
response was no
and what the key here with differential
privacy at least in this particular
example differential privacy is the bob
only in the bob knows this information
actually bobox knows this as well but
the investigator or the instructor only
gets did they see this response and the
part what the privacy guarantees are
that i i get to see a noisy version of a
sensory response and that noisy version
is essentially controlled by that
essentially area of that green red and
blue triangle essentially in fact this
little exact proportion corresponds in
epsilon 1.1 but if you actually maximize
it this way it corresponds to an s 1.1
at 0.5 and notice that the blue blue
area where it both must answer honestly
it gets smaller that means there's less
privacy loss and if you can imagine a
step sound goes up
blue increases so there's more privacy
loss okay so higher epsilon more privacy
loss lower so on complex privacy loss
now
this this you can theoretically just
apply to rcts and be done with it but
what we realized when we actually did
this experiment is that people lie
students lie okay and if you ever taught
a course about certain uh anything when
they get excuses not everyone lies but
at least one house says everyone lies
and what happened
was his followers so we gave this and we
thought
if if the bob spinner lands here says no
bob might actually not follow this
instruction as advertised and then fab
might say you know maybe
he doesn't want to say that he didn't
pay attention lecture to an instructor
directly or maybe just bob just you know
human nature wants lie irrespective of
the question itself or because bob can
lie and he will lie okay so what happens
is sometimes that bob will actually even
though the spinners landed in red and
bob is supposed to answer no but i might
actually say yes okay and so he deviated
from what we wanted him to do and
actually reports him and yes okay now as
the pi i don't know from this whether he
lied or not i think he followed this but
then maybe he was lying in the process
this is a realistic problem that we face
when you're actually doing this
and what we actually figured out is that
there is actually a way to detect
cheaters so this is known as cheaters uh
people who actually deviate from the
protocol by doing a very simple trick to
dp algorithm differentiate private
algorithms the idea is essentially
instead of having one differential
private algorithm you have two
differential private algorithms that are
just slightly different and then you
just split the sample into two parts and
then you give one differential private
algorithm to one group of people and
they give the other side a
other people and you compare the
outcomes between the two and by doing
this you can actually get how many
people are cheaters and you can actually
de-bias your cheater estimate so that's
what this slide says essentially
and this isn't
a new idea actually if you dig far back
there are some very very uh clever
people in uh experimental psychology
where you're trying to detect cheaters
in a completely different sense we just
added a modern flavor by adding samples
for them really and that's also the
classic idea but just you know just kind
of can't this idea of sample splitting
comes up frequently in recent machine
learning
and that's the idea that we did to
detect this kind of deviation from bob
being the cheater and to know how that
jeter uh
decontaminate our scientific responses
we essentially gave two different uh we
can give two different differential
private algorithms and then get the
responses and essentially measure the
deviation between what we expect the
number of yeses to be from what we
observe and that difference essentially
amounts uh that difference you can use
to quantify the number of cheaters and
then to unbiased your estimates and so
yes hypothetically
if
let's say everyone always like always
missed it
this will be able to detect that no so
if everyone cheats and we want to give
you an ate estimate right if everyone
says no it's yes and there's no way to
scientifically even get what you wanted
to say so actually we're going to talk
about information
the
cheating is allowed to depend on red
so so this is our our our prcts two
simple ideas is brought together samples
putting on top of it so the idea is
people we enroll people in their case
students and we randomly we collect the
pre-treatment covariates and there's an
art to that by the way
we randomly split the sample so we
randomly sub divide a student into two
groups one group gets one a particular
spinner the other group is under a
particular spinner we then randomize the
treatment within each of these subgroups
gather their outcome data
and
their treatment assignment and the s is
what simple you're then and then all the
external copiers what we don't get to
see is where the bob spinners landed
their actual response whether they're
cheater or not so we the investigator
only gets to see some privatized noisy
version of response the treatment
assignment a
the sample split where the sample were
and then the code varies yes do the
students see the proportions or they
only see the color
they can see the color or proportion it
actually wouldn't and they can cheat
based on those proportions as well
what's critical here is that they cannot
cheat based on the whether they're
assigned treatment or control so that's
a big assumption that we have to make to
actually get ate estimates so we'll talk
about the possibility of that assumption
in our case but yeah so what's the truth
today a treatment here is actually i
think we'll talk about the very end but
essentially whether you have an
instructor face present in a zoom
lecture versus instructure phase action
so this is one of the questions that
people our department wants to ask is
whether we should whether the instructor
should turn on a video while they're
lecturing versus whether they can turn
off the video audio sufficient okay
so compared to an rcs your regular rct
how does it differ one of the two we
just had two steps one step is to
essentially this random splitting part
we have to do initially and the other
part is to have the differential privacy
algorithm in between but beyond those
with the regular step remains the same
as before
and here is our the
specific algorithm the parameters we use
but the key thing that we want to prove
in the first thing about this algorithm
is that this algorithm produces uh
differentially private responses yeah
whatever response you get uh it's
differentiate private now the key here
is that we only can guarantee
differential privacy among non-cheaters
those who actually follow the algorithm
if they don't follow the algorithm let's
say they let's say decided to
uh do let's say they're trying to be
clever and they give always the opposite
of their true responses by differential
privacy you can actually you can design
an algorithm where it can actually
detect backwards so what we can
guarantee is that if you decide to truly
follow the algorithm we can guarantee
differential privacy but if you decide
to be clever and cheat
somebody might be able to actually
discover what your true responses are so
that could be something to advertise
when you actually do this
okay
there's also properties of differential
private response being immune and to
propose processing and all these other
things or not but essentially the idea
is that i can give you a differential
private response and you can do all
kinds of processing on it but you won't
be able to recover back the original
response so that was proven
by dork and i was summarized in this
book here
now let's talk about identification so
we guarantee that our data set uh the
out response treatment is differentiated
private what about the identification of
treatment effects so in a typical rct we
typically assume these things stable
super
the treatment of randomized and
positively overlap this will be
satisfied in the rct and it'll be also
satisfied in our case and then if you do
this you can identify this by again the
difference in means treatment control
now what the rpi ct also does by
satisfies by design is that the random
samples wouldn't happen that we
initially randomly so examples but that
we actually the spinner is randomized so
we can actually run the spinner runs at
random they can choose to react to that
spin how they want but the spinner
itself is running
and then the the randomness uh this is
just to formalize things this is that
the
treatment was randomized at the end of
the day okay so those are also satisfied
by design okay
now the two things that we have to
assume in addition to uh these what we
call this satisfied by design
are as follows the first one is that the
cheater's response to the investigator
is independent to the treatment
assignment conditional on the the
splitting variable
the uh the the spinner variable and uh
and the spin whether it's spinner landed
so essentially in respect once you have
these variables the cheaters are not
trying to change the response to change
your response to the investigator if
they got the treatment they might
respond differently maybe they got the
control they might respond to something
else okay
now this will be plausible if the
treatment is blinded or if the two
people don't react differently in
different ways but this is not plausible
if the treatment is definitely unblinded
so this is some of the things that we
have to a heroic assumption so we have
to make to make identification possible
the second one just says that there's an
honest dataset and so that's just we
have to believe that there's hopefully
honest people in the dataset okay
and so if those things are possible
then what we can show is that we can
identify the treatment effect among
honest people okay uh that is that this
tau h which is treatment effect honest
people can be identified by
this formula here
and the proportion of cheaters can also
be identified by this little complicated
formula here
now uh just to give you a sense of what
that result means
suppose the entire data contains all
honest participants that will mean that
what using our prct we can actually
identify the ate while guaranteeing at
the same time differential privacy in
contrast the usual rct would just be
able to identify the ate but the outcome
itself might be not it's not
differentiate private
now let's say take the case where all
the of them are cheaters there's not a
single honest person in the study
population so that would be a very
pessimistic view of the world and if
that's the case then there's no way that
an rprct or level on rct can actually
identify a scientific quantity of
interest so that's the other end of the
spectrum now in between
is there's some honest participants and
there are some not so honest
participants and so in the in that case
our prc identifies eight amongst the
honest participants and guarantees not
and among those honest participants
guarantees different privacy
and actually if you think about this a
little bit carefully and i've worked in
iv for a long time this is actually very
similar to local average treatment
effect among compliers in the sense that
i can't identify who the complier i
can't define who the cheaters and the
non-cheaters are but i can identify
their proportion and i can identify the
treatment effect among the non-honest
books as well so actually identification
result actually is just very there's a
lot of parallels between those two
assumptions
now
once you've loaded even at five there's
estimators doing this so under ict
that's the estimator under our prct
essentially it's a difference in means
estimator just divided by some
proportion of cheaters and the
spinner ratios
and if you do this you get an asymptotic
number estimate you can do inference and
you can also estimate this
quantity consistently the variance
quantity consistently
now the more interesting part was the
how much are we losing by using our prct
we're essentially injecting additional
noise to the outcome to guarantee
privacy and so we're going to be losing
a couple of efficiency characteristics
and so this is a
formula that my student took a while to
derive but essentially characterizes how
long how long it arrives at but the key
ideas follows this ratio between the two
variances of the uh our estimate under
the differential private data versus the
rp the regular rct where the outcome is
not private
is going to be growing based on the
number uh growing and monotonically
increasing as a function of the privacy
loss parameter epsilon okay
and only when the privacy loss is
infinite where do we get the same
variance estimates so essentially we bet
that so we're going to always be losing
amounts someone by actually adding some
noise to this thing now there's been a
question about in our least in our uh
when we're dealing with when we're
designing experiment how do we actually
go about specifying this epsilon
quantity so this thing
you have to know a couple of things you
you once you know this formula you can
kind of have a tolerance for how much
relative efficiency you're losing the
other thing is whether these tau zero
top one is the the effect estimates and
under the control and the outcome that
may be informed by subject matter
experts there's a power analysis that
people might do in a clinical trial that
you kind of have to kind of assume and
then the recommended data privacy
standards that may not exist currently
but hopefully it will get standardized
and the union clinical trials just
hopefully gets adopted in the future so
in our child we set apps on v2 which is
matching the apple health data
[Music]
because the thing is if they're not if
they're both if there's some cheaters
and the rprc identifies the slightly
different quantity than the rct actually
so the efficiency characteristics
doesn't make sense because the biases
are not different and so when they're
all honest
we still wanted to know okay let's let's
just i don't know if they're honest but
let's assume if they're honest if i run
an rpr city versus an rct how much are
we losing by injecting an edition
that's why the efficiency characters
make sense
that's an apple's definition
any other questions
okay
so
additional thing that we've done was we
have realized that this we're going to
be losing a lot of power
and so we need a cover adjustment to
make it more efficient so we have a
cover adjustment estimator that actually
is essentially an extension of the
augmented inverse probability weighted
estimator that some of the talks
mentioned
uh it's estimated in consistent even if
the outcome model is wrong so it's a
nice way to do this actually what's more
important is that actually you need to
ask the right kind of coherent questions
to actually improve efficiency something
that we realize when you're actually
designing this trial okay but there is
an estimator and the exact formula is in
the paper
so let's get to the actual trial
so it's rare for our statistician to
actually collect data and actually
design collect and go through the entire
process
and my phd student apparently was one of
the few students in our department that
actually went through a trial collecting
the data below the analysis and
methodology development so thankfully we
were tasked with this task of how do you
assessing the quality of online lectures
that when uh many of berkeley probably
included mit including other places
probably a lot of the courses went
online and there are some questions
about what's the most effective way of
delivering lectures online and so one of
the things that we did was uh a specific
one question that we studied was whether
turning on lecture video cameras was
effective or does that change learning
outcomes at the end of the day okay now
there are prior studies
uh that suggests that students pay
attention more penetration if they're
like if the instructors are present in
lectures and if comparative they're not
and unfortunately when you actually want
to get this data
uh it's all probably it's all locked up
and there's no way to actually get the
individual level data so this is a
problem and there's no way to replicate
in order to combine the datasets you can
get more power so what we do is we use
an rprc to test this hypothesis does
having instructors present in lecture
online lecture improve improve attention
versus not having that lecture
and so we ran this uh literally about a
year ago uh recruit undergrad students
and then uh we recruited 72 students we
set the apps on the day what apple
health at least one their white paper
released to be their health standards so
this we think it's fairly private
and we can also publicly share this
individual level data so you can see
their individual outcomes all the
coherence that they've accepted
and in fact this took a lot longer
convincing the irb that we can actually
release individual level educational
level data
uh but they were able uh thankfully i
also want to thank the irb officer for
actually going through the process of
explaining differential privacy what
that means and how that impacts in
science and clinical trials so
what was the actual trial uh so this is
essentially my graduate student um we
were lecturing them about rcts
so there's a little pun there where one
of the the students in the control arm
did not get to see uh my uh
graduate student and the treatment group
the student got to see my grad student
talk about rct okay and they're about 37
or 35 in each group
coverts are balanced the uh the paper
goes into details about the fact that it
was randomized
and then what the fr that the spinner
was essentially
my graduate student learned javascript
and actually
ran uh wrote this code to where the
student will roll the die and then based
on the
how to die lands they could uh either
answer yes to a question always know or
answer honestly okay
and so uh the student actually uh we
told the student a priority about that
there could be a die that's in the
process and so that's and the priorities
die uh probabilities or sets of the
privacy loss is exactly two okay
and so the results so one of the
questions that we asked is uh did you
did you find it hard to pay attention to
the lecture video on rct okay and you
did it yes or no
and in fact using our prct which
guarantees differential privacy we found
that as expected if students find it
easier to pay attention when they're
when there's a instructor present
actually speaking to them rather than
some
voice just speaking from the rct
in fact we can get the confidence
interval for this
uh and then
we also estimated twenty four percent
cheers okay so not everyone's honest
and this all results also these previous
rts uh without using the differential
privacy characteristics yes
sir what scale is percent
yes thank you yes the thirty one percent
uh relative differences in proportions
yes
thank you
and yeah again just to make sure that
these the data is differently private
and so individual level data can be
shared for replication or data fusion if
you wanted to combine multiple rct
styles and to actually get more power
okay so this is a summary of our paper
so we provide a new experimental design
we bust a private rct
that guarantees differential privacy
online estimation of cable effects uh
these one particular cool aspect about
this design is robust against cheaters
who might deviate from protocol and
we're able to detect this tutors and
correct for that to apply correct for
that bias by using the sample splitting
and using a slightly two different dp
algorithms to actually detect this okay
and the rpsct can estimate the ate among
non-cheaters um
there's also double robust estimators
for this
and then we found through actually
running this trial with n78 samples so
it's not a big sample that we're
actually able to detect that people
having your face on a lecture is
actually helpful in getting students
engaged so maybe this is a takeaway i
don't know if it generalizes to every
university but hopefully it could be
something that could be useful
there's also trade-offs between relative
efficiency and privacy that we explored
there are some future directions that uh
my future current students are working
on uh efficiency balance uh how to
optimally design different private
algorithms so there's an entire work on
local differential privacy getting
feedback to actually optimize these
things or trying to figure out the easy
way to actually convince the irb officer
that's also differentiated private
versus just a spinner being
differentially private and then better
ways to estimate this cheater proportion
currently we're using a lagrangian way
to do this but i think we can actually
if there's possible to predict cheater
status maybe by certain type covariates
it could be helpful so we're not
currently including how do we we're not
using cover to predict uh cheap
proportion of cheaper right now we're
just doing it by just simple differences
yeah i just wanted to thank everyone i
involved it took uh my several phd
students the entire department's
administrative staff and convincing many
instructors uh to help us and to tailor
these questions how to properly ask
these questions so really i want to
thank the entire uw-madison staff
department for a junior faculty trying
to run this trial and getting this out
and also helping my graduate student to
do so and also mike biopke for some
advice on how to tailor the irb process
and thank you for your time
thank you let's move on to the panel
discussion and
so the three speaker